say you're starting a football team
who's qb1 you're saying the Dodgers and
the Dodgers D going with kers kers is
qb1 I would choose
me you like a Kyler Murray dog who's uh
your defensive end my defensive end
we're going we're need someone big and
athletic there's one big athletic dude
on our team I'm thinking like Bobby
Miller like he's a big guy who are you
thinking I would go with gral you think
he moves quick enough to be defensive
end gral is one of the most athletic
people on our team really you don't know
that wide receiver one I was going to
pick you okay so I'm your wide receiver
one yeah I think I will probably go with
Joe Kelly what about uh running back Co
long CO's fast dude I'm going outman I
got outman more like a linebacker okay
so what about your kicker I'll go with
Miggy Rog cuz migy loves soccer does Kik
play soccer I know none of us know how
to play soccer